MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WELCOME TO OUR FIRST POLICY
HEARING. OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL HAVE A QUORUM IF ONE MORE
ONE MORE ONE MORE MEMBER SHOWS
UP- WE HAVE THE COMMITTEE RULES
TO ADOPT TODAY AND WE HAVE
ELEVEN BILLS. NINE OF THOSE ARE
RECOMMENDED ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AND THE OTHER TWO
BILLS BY THE WAY ARE. DO HAVE
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATIONS. AS YOU
KNOW DUE TO THE- VIRUS OVER
NINETEEN WE HAVE LIMITED ROOM
AVAILABLE FOR THE PUBLIC IN
THIS ROOM. AND IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY FIVE AT THE STATE
CAPITOL WHICH IS THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND- INTEGRAL SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH THE QUORUM.
DALY HERE MAYES HERE BERMAN.
BIGELOW CHEN. COOLEY COOPER
FRAZIER. GIPSON GRAYSON.
RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL. WHAT. WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. MISTER
COOPER IS ENTERING THE CHAMBER
SO. WE REALLY HAVE A QUORUM.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
BY CALLING. 877-692-8957. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN.
OR BY VISITING THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE IT A. I. N. S. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT C. A. DOT G. O. V.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. AND
SHARED WITH THE PUBLIC HOW THEY
MAY PARTICIPATE- LET'S ADOPT
THE COMMITTEE RULES IS THERE A
MOTION. GET A MOTION AND A
SECOND. MOTION BY MOISTURE
MAYES SECOND BY MR BIGELOW AND-
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
RULES. IF NOT LET'S VOTE ROLL
CALL PLEASE. ON THE COMMITTEE
ROLES DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES
AYE MAYES AYE BERMAN. BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CHAN CHEN I COOLEY.
COOPER COOPER AYE FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON. GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL I
WOULD. WOULD I. DID YOU SAY
NINE OR NINE VOTES. GREAT GREAT
THANK YOU AND BY THE WAY I WANT
TO A HIGHLIGHT AND INTRODUCE.
OUR NEW CHIEF CONSULTANT-
KATHLEEN O'MALLEY. IS OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT. RIGHT HERE. AND THE.
WE'RE IN WE'RE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE SOMEONE WITH SUCH
EXPERIENCE AND TALENT AND-
INTEGRITY. TO A SERVICE OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT- THE OTHER.
WHAT'S CLAIRE'S TITLE. KEEP
PRINCIPAL THE PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT IS CLEAR WENT- SHE'S
NOT ABE TO ATTEND HERE BECAUSE
OF THE RULES THAT WE HAVE BUT-
SOON ALABI I KNOW YOUR STAFF
STARTED DEALING WITH CLAIRE.
AND SHE'S OUTSTANDING AS WELL-
WE HAVE NINE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AB FOUR OH ONE
AB SEVENTY FOUR AB THREE NINE
SEVEN AB FOUR NINETY FOUR AB
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT. A. B.
1-540-115-6215 SIXTY THREE AND
FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR TOLAND NINE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE'S MOTION SECOND MOTION
MOTION BY MISTER FRAZIER SECOND
BY MR GRAYSON ANY QUESTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. IF NOT
TO. LET'S DO A ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES HI.
MAYES AYE BERMAN. BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CHAN CHEN AYE
COOLEY. COOPER COOPER I FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON. GRAYSON
GRAYSON HI RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ
AYE VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD. WHAT
I. THANK YOU. THERE WERE NINE
AYE VOTES FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
SO THE TWO REMAINING ITEMS- ARE
AB ONE TWO THREE BY. ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GONZALEZ IN AB FIVE FIVE
THREE. BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
ACTUALLY SENATOR NOW SENATOR
COM LOGGER. DO WE KNOW THEIR
WHEREABOUTS WE HEARD ANYTHING
FROM THE TWO OF THEM. I SPOKE
WITH MS GONZALEZ EARLIER TODAY
AND SHE HAD A BILL SHE WAS
PRESENTING OVER AND NOW
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. I THINK
SHE HAS A COUPLE OF OTHER.
SENATOR COM LOGGER IS ON HER
WAY. SO WERE. WE'LL DO AB. FIVE
FIVE THREE. BY COM LOGGER WE'LL
DO THAT WHEN NEXT.
I DON'T KNOW
IF THE SET IF THE SENATE WAS IN
SESSION. THIS MORNING. ASSEMBLY
WAR.
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THE TO
CENTER CALM WATERS COMING- IN
THE CASE OF. IS GONZALEZ. SHE
INDICATED THAT SHE WAS GONNA
HAVE A HARD TIME. GETTING HERE
BECAUSE OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE.
ARE THE MEMBERS COMFORTABLE
FIVE PRESENT GONZALEZ IS BILL.
OKAY I'M GONNA DO THAT I WAS
ABOUT TO DO IT BUT- MS CALM
WATERS HERE. WELCOME. YOU WERE
A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE SO
WE GAVE YOU WERE GIVEN YOU
EXTRA COURTESY. THAT'S WHY
YOU'RE THE BEST CHAIR WELL
THANK YOU. EVERYONE'S NOT IN
THEIR HEADS TO THE PEOPLE'S.
THIS IS BEAUTIFUL. YEAH THERE'S
A COUPLE ANYONE WHO'S THE CHAIR
THERE LIKE A COUPLE WHO WERE A
OUR DISAGREEMENTS ARE WELCOME
MISS CALM WATER THIS IS ON AB
FIVE FIVE THREE PET INSURANCE
YES SIR THANK YOU COULD AFTER
NOON GOOD MORNING STILL MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING AB FIVE FIVE THREE.
TO REQUIRE PET INSURANCE
POLICIES SOLD IN RENEWED IN
CALIFORNIA TO FULLY COVER
SPAYING AND NEUTERING OF PETS
AND ANY VETERINARY EXPENSES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE SERVICES
SO ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY.
NATIONAL PET OWNERS SURVEY
CONDUCTED BY THE AMERICAN PET
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION SIXTY
SEVEN. PERCENT OF U. S.
HOUSEHOLDS OR ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION FAMILIES OWN A PET. AND
WE KNOW THAT THAT NUMBER WENT
UP AS A RESULT OF CODED- WITH
ALL THE THERAPY PUPS AND
KITTIES THAT. WERE ADOPTED THE
A. P. P. A. ALSO REPORTS THAT
23% OF DOGS AND 31% OF CATS ARE
OBTAINED FROM AN ANIMAL SHELTER
OR HUMANE SOCIETY BUT- 72% OF
DOGS IN 64% OF CATS. ARE
OBTAINED THROUGH FRIENDS
RELATIVES BREEDERS STRAY OR
PRIVATE PARTY. CALIFORNIA FUNDS
TO PROGRAMS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S PREVENTION FUND
PROGRAM AND THE PET LOVERS
LICENSE PLATE PROGRAM TO BE
USED TO PROVIDE LOW COST OR
FREE SPAY NEUTER SERVICES FOR
DOGS AND CATS OWNED BY
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. THESE DOLLARS ACTUALLY
GO TO CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO OFFSET THE COSTS OF SPAYING
AND NEUTERING PETS. AND WE KNOW
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE-
STRAY ANIMALS OFTEN OR NON
WANTED ANIMALS OFTEN END UP
EUTHANIZED WHICH IS ALSO AN
INCREDIBLE COST TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES. IN FACT ACCORDING TO
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR THE
PREVENTION OF CRUELTY TO
ANIMALS EACH YEAR APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION SHELTER
ANIMALS ARE EUTHANIZED. THE
OVERPOPULATION OF UNWANTED AND
SURRENDERED PETS NOT ONLY
RESULTS IN MILLIONS OF ANIMALS
BEING EUTHANIZED EACH YEAR BUT
PUTS PRESSURE ON THELIMITED
RESOURCES PUBLIC RESOURCES. TO
CARE FOR AND FIND HOMES FOR
THESE ANIMALS. THE SHEER SCALE
OF TACKLING PET OVERPOPULATION
CAN APPEAR OVERWHELMING BUT
THERE ARE SMALL STEPS. TO
PROTECT THIS UNNECESSARY
SUFFERING WE KNOW THAT STATES
HAVE RESPONDED BY ADOPTING LAWS
THAT MAKE IT MANDATORY FOR
RELEASING AGENCIES TO HAVE.
DOGS AND CATS SPAYED OR
NEUTERED. THE MAJORITY OF THESE
LAWS ARE DIRECTED AT NEW
OWNERS. ADOPTING PETS FROM
POUNDS SHELTERS OR LOCAL HUMANE
SOCIETIES AB FIVE FIVE THREE
WOULD REQUIRE PET INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO JOIN THE COMBINED
EFFORTS. OF SHELTERS ANIMAL
OWNERS BREEDERS AND
VETERINARIANS TO TACKLE THE
OVER POPULATIONS BY REQUIRING
THE POLICIES TO FULLY COVER
SPAYED AND NEUTERED. AND
ASSOCIATIVE VETERINARY EXPENSES
THIS EFFORT WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THE RECENT SURGE OF ANIMAL
ADOPTIONS WILL NOT FURTHER
EXACERBATE ANIMAL.
OVERPOPULATION AND PET
HOMELESSNESS HELLO IN OUR STATE.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF MICHAEL
MARTINEZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND SUSAN TAYLOR WITH
ACTORS AND OTHERS FOR ANIMALS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- THIS IS THE IS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
WITNESSES TO JOIN THE HEARING
MISTER MARTINEZ ARE YOU. ARE
YOU THERE YES SIR I AM HERE GO
AHEAD SIR THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU SURE DAILY GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
COMMISSIONER LOT IS VERY PROUD
TO BE THE SPONSOR OF THIS
MEASURE AND WE THANK SENATOR
COM LONGER FOR HER LEADERSHIP
IN OFFERING THIS MEASURE. SO ME
JUST JUMP RIGHT TO THREE MAIN
REASONS WHY WE ARE PURSUING AB
FIVE FIVE THREE THIS YEAR.
FIRSTLY THIS BILL IS PART OF
THE STATE'S LONGSTANDING
COMMITMENT TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF ANIMALS IN OUR SHELTERS AS
OUR STATE AGGRESSIVELY WORKS
TOWARDS BECOMING A NO KILL
STATE. DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
HAVE SEEN A SKYROCKET OF PET
ADOPTIONS FROM NOT JUST
SHELTERS BUT ALSO PET BREEDERS
AN ONLINE PET SALES. I THANK
YOU ALL THAT WE CAN SO THESE
CAN DEMOCRATS DO NOT ADD MORE
TO THE ALREADY STAGGERING
ANIMAL OVER POPULATION IN OUR
STATE. AND THE ONLY SURE WAY TO
DO THIS IS THROUGH
STERILIZATION. SECONDLY THIS
BILL HELPS PROMOTE NECESSARY
ACCESS TO CARE. FOR THE
SPANIARD OR SERVICES. TODAY
ONLY THE MOST EXPENSIVE HEALTH
INSURANCE POLICIES COVER SPAY
AND NEUTER SURGERIES. MEANWHILE
FOR MANY OF THE LESS EXPENSIVE
PET INSURANCE POLICIES THAT
DON'T COVER NEUTER AND SPAY
SERVICES THE INSURANCE COMPANY
DOES ONE OF TWO THINGS IT CAN
IT CAN MANDATE THAT PET OWNERS
CHAPTER COVERED PET SPAYED OR
NEUTERED ON THEIR OWN.
FORETASTE CERTAIN COVERAGE
EXCLUSIONS. OR IT MAKES THE PET
OWNER PURCHASED ADDITIONAL ADD
ON BONUS PLANS IN ORDER TO
COVER EXPAND YOUR SERVICE BUT-
WE BELIEVE IT'S UNFAIR TO
CONSUMERS BUT A LOT OF
INSURANCE COMPANIES. PROVIDE
LITTLE TO NO COVERAGE FOR
STERILIZATION BUT AT THE SAME
TIME. EXCLUDE COVERAGE FOR
ILLNESSES CAUSED BY NON
STERILIZATION. THIRDLY ALTHOUGH
THE BILL COULD IMPOSE A SMALL
PREMIUM COSTS AND POLICY
HOLDERS TO COVER A ONE TIME
PROCEDURE. WE BELIEVE IT'S A
SMALL CONSTIPATED PREVENT
FUTURE PET HEALTH PROBLEMS
DECREASE COSTS CLEAR THAT FOR
THE- LAST UNNECESSARY
EUTHANASIA. OF LIVING ANIMALS
AND ULTIMATELY IN THE LONG RUN
REDUCE INSURED LOSSES TO. IN
CLOSING WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
TACKLE THE ISSUE OF ANIMAL OVERPOPULATION EVERY ANGLE WE
CAN'T. LOCAL SHELTERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
STERILIZATION SERVICES CANNOT
MEET THIS DEMAND ALONE
ESPECIALLY WHEN SOME SHELTERS
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO PERMANENTLY
CLOSED BECAUSE OF BUDGET CUTS.
YOU TO THE PANDEMIC OR DO NOT
HAVE ANY APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE
BECAUSE OF THE OVERWHELMING
DEMAND FOR THE SERVICES. THE
FIFTEEN SEVEN I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR ITEMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTINEZ AND-
MISS TAYLOR ARE YOU THERE. YES
I AM PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS SUSAN TAYLOR AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
ACTORS AND OTHERS FOR ANIMAL IT
pBECAUSE THERE ARE MORE SERVICES
AND LAWS THAT REQUIRE SPAY
NEUTER THAT THERE IS NO PROBLEM
WITH THAT WE CAN LOWER OUR
GUARD. THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
SAY THEY ARE NOT A DRIVER FOR
OVER POPULATION NO ONE HAS SAID
THEY WERE BUT NO ONE CAN SAY
HOW MANY OF THEIR CLIENTS
REMAIN ON STERILIZED AND WE
PRODUCE. STATISTICS USED FOR
PUBLIC DISSEMINATION WE PHOTO
ANIMALS IN SHELTERS NO ONE
KNOWS HOW MANY ANIMALS ARE IN
THE HOMES ARE ON THE STREETS WE
PRODUCING IT FIFTY YEARS LATER
AS ONE AS ONLY ONE ORGANIZATION
WE ARE STILL GOING STRONG THE
PROBLEM IS STILL WITH US. WE
AGO IN THE MISSION OF SPAY
NEUTER AND HAVE EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
PROCEDURES WE ARE IN A UNIQUE
POSITION BUT BECAUSE WE PROVIDE
SPAY NEUTER HELP AND THEN DEAL
WITH DISTRAUGHT PET GUARDIANS
WHEN THEY'RE ON STERILIZED PETS
BECOME SERIOUSLY ILL WITH LIFE
THREATENING AND EXPENSE OF
HEALTH PROBLEMS. ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON WE SEE IS FILE ME
TRACK WITH A URINE'S INFECTION
THAT IS TOTALLY AVOIDED BY
STAYING IT IS OFTEN
UNRECOGNIZED AND CAN BE FATAL.
LAST YEAR WE HELPED WITH FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN MEDICAL
PROCEDURES FIFTY ONE OF WHICH
WERE FOR BY A MAJOR OR MAMMARY
TUMORS THAT IS 10% IT IS UNFAIR
FOR TO CONSUMERS AND INSURANCE
COMPANIES PROVIDE LITTLE TO NO
COVERAGE FOR STERILIZATION BUT
AT THE SAME TIME EXCLUDE%
COVERAGE FOR ILLNESSES CAUSED
BY NON STERILIZATION. STAINER
IS THE ONLY SURE WAY TO STOP WE
PRODUCTION AND PROVIDES
IMPORTANT HEALTH BENEFITS IT
ALSO HELPS WITH STOPPING
PENSION AID FROM ROAMING AND
POSSIBLY GETTING HIT BY CAR.
PESTERS THEIR LIVES ONLY ONCE
SO ONLY ONE PLANE AND AT FIFTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION ESTIMATES
THAT MOST OF THEIR CLIENTS
ALREADY OR SPAY NEUTER BEEN
ACOSTA WILL ARE MARGINAL DURING
THIS PAST YEAR WE HAVE ALL FACE
SOCIAL ISOLATION AND TURNED TO
OUR PETS FOR COMPANIONSHIP. AND
HELP IN REDUCING AND SIGN THE
END OF PRESSURE. THEY ARE PART
OF OUR- WE SHOULD TREAT THEM AS-
I RESPECTFULLY WE- A YES VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU MISS
TAYLOR- ARE THERE ANY PERSON
SIR ON THE PHONE IN LINE- WHO
WOULD LIKE. TO SPEAK TO US IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO STATE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AB FIVE FIVE THREE YOU
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE SEVERAL IN
Q. MOBILE FIRST ONLINE TWENTY
EIGHT TO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
BURKE THIS IS JENNIFER
APPEARING HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE FIVE THREE ON IN BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA CLEAR
DRY THOUGH. THANK YOU. THINGS
ONLINE TWENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN.
BUXAR MISTER CHAIR TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI MY
NAME IS NICOLAS JACQUET
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
OR SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE OTHER LINE
THIS LINE TWENTY NINE TO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SHARING
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE RUNNING
PUBLIC POLICY GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY IN THE BILL OF. THE
CAP OR TO SEE IF SOMEONE IS
SUPPORT EACH. THANK YOU. AND I
THINK I HEARD YOU SAY THAT IS
THE- TOTALITY OF THE. FOLK
SINCE WE DO HAVE A- A LATE
ARRIVAL IF YOU HAVE JUST A
MOMENT STRUCTURE. SLY NUMBER
THIRTY TWO THREE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JOE
CONTENT FROM PUBLIC COUNCIL IN
LOS ANGELES WE'RE CALLING TO-
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. AND I.
THAT CONCLUDES THE. SUPPORT
WITNESSES SANDRA COLLINS AND
WE'LL GO NOW TO THE OPPOSE
WITNESSES- THERE ARE TWO THAT
I'VE BEEN INFORMED OF- CHRIS
ROSA ON BEHALF OF THE NORTH
AMERICAN PET HEALTH INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION. AND INDIANA LOOK
pTOWARD YOUR KEEN PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA- MISS ROSE ARE YOU
THERE. I'M HERE NEXT YEAR GOOD
MORNING TO YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS. CRITTERS ON BEHALF OF
THE NORTH AMERICAN PET HEALTH
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION WHOSE
MEMBERS MAKE UP 99% OF THE PET
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS IN THAT
STATE. FIRST OF ALL- IF YOU
PORTANTINO'S THAT NAPPY MEMBERS
SHARE SENATOR CALL MARGARET
BOTH IN CREATING PET THERE WAS
A XIN RATE IN CALIFORNIA.
BEIJING HAS YOU KNOW PLEASE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN PET HEALTH
AND REDUCE THE- OF PET
OVERPOPULATION. HOWEVER WHERE
WE DISAGREE IS ON THE SOLUTION-
THE COMMISSION PROPOSED BY THE-
AND- MANDATE ON ALL PET
INSURANCE PRODUCTS CANNOT
ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL FOR SEVERAL
REASONS. FIRST OFF. TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM OF HOMEWORK PACKET
OVER POPULATION WE MUST FOCUS
ON THE POPULATION OF ANIMALS
DRIVING NOT PROBLEM. THE BILL
STACK SHEETS CORRECTLY
IDENTIFIED POPULATION OF AT THE
NEED TO STERILIZATION THE FACT
SHE STATE THAT EIGHTY SEVEN
PERCENT. OF UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES HAVE DIFFICULTIES
ACCESSING VETERINARY SERVICES
FOR STERILIZATION. THIS IS NOT
BE INSURED POPULATION PLEASE
NOTE THAT ENSURED PAT ARE
ALREADY LARGELY STERILIZED
BEFORE THEY BECOME INSURED. 87%
OF PACKAGE ONE YEARS OF AGE ARE
ALREADY STERILIZED AT THE TIME
OF THE MOMENT IN NINETY THREE
PERCENT. A POPULAR TWO YEARS
OLD HAVE ALREADY BEEN
STERILIZED AT THE TIME OF THE
MOMENT BASED ON THE DATA THIS
BILL WOULD FORCE CONSUMERS TO
PAY FOR STERILIZATION COVERAGE
AND YET THEY CANNOT USE THE
STERILIZATION COVERAGE THAT
THEY PAY FOR BECAUSE YOU.
CANNOT BE STERILIZED TWICE.
CONSUMERS ALTHOUGH. NUMBER DO
NOT WANT TO BE TO PAY FOR
SERVICES THAT THEY CAN USE NOT
ONLY ARE YOU FORCED PET PARENTS
SHE FOR COVERAGE THEY CAN'T USE
YOU ARE NOT SOLVING THE PROBLEM
OVER TOP OF PETS BECAUSE THE-
INJURED PAT ARE NOT
CONTRIBUTING TO THE HOMELESS
AND THEIR ALLIES TO POPULATE.
UNDER THE CAPOUE BY THE-
PREMIUMS WILL UP. AND POTENTIAL
CALLED. WILL LOOK AFTER THE- OF
WHAT THE MATH PAPER THE PRODUCT
AND ONE WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD
THEY WANT TO FIND AFTER PET
INSURANCE WHEN THEY'RE FORCED
TO PAY FOR COVERAGE THEY CANNOT
USE. THIS TO THE SECOND PROBLEM
WITH THAT SO THERE IS NO NEED
TO MANDATE THEIR REALIZATION
COVERAGE BECAUSE THEIR
REALIZATION COVERAGE ALREADY
EXIST IN THE MARKET IF YOU NEED
IT AND ONE. THIS IS WHY WORK.
KERN IT HAD HEARING HAS THE
NEED FOR COVER THEY CAN BE IT
MAKING WELLNESS THAT COVERS
LIKE STERILE. DENTAL CLEANING
ACUPUNCTURE IF A PET PARENT
ALREADY STERILIZED PETS ISSUES
ACROSS THAT DOESN'T COVER
STERILIZATION BECAUSE AGAIN WE
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY FOR WHAT
YOU CANNOT USE. OUR WORK WITH
POLICY HOLDERS CHAU WHAT THAT
THIS IS WHAT PARENTS PREFER.
THEY WANT TO CHOI TO PAY FOR
WHAT THEY NEED. WE LIKE THE
OPTION OF BUYING STERILIZATION
IF THEY NEED IT AND BE LIKE NOT
HAVING TO PAY FOR IT IF THEIR
PET IS ALREADY STERILIZED THIS
TYPE OF P. IN REPORT. IS A
FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENT OF THE PET
INSURANCE INDUSTRY. THIRD
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IT'S A
MATTER OF EQUITY AND PASSING
ALONG THE COST OF STERILIZATION
FROM PREFAIR ALIVE SHELTER PETS.
WHO WOULD BE FORCED TO PAY FOR
THE COVERAGE EVEN THOUGH THEY
CANNOT USE IT THEMSELVES
BECAUSE SHELTER PETS ARE
ADOPTED KERALITE HERE'S WHAT I
MEAN BY THIS EQUITY ISSUE.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
ANY PET ADOPTED FROM A SHELTER
OR RESCUE TO BE STERILIZED IF
THIS BILL BECOMES LAW. AT THE
OWNER WHO ADOPT A SHELTER PET
ISSUES IS TO PURCHASE. HEALTH
INSURANCE WOULD BE FORCED TO
PAY FOR THE STERILIZATION
COVERAGE THEY CANNOT DO AND IT
IS FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR TO
REQUIRE THESE PET PARENTS USED
TO SUBSIDIZE. THE COST OF
STERILIZATION OF AN EXPENSIVE
SURPRISE IT WOULD BOTTOM OF
LEADERS WHO THE OWNER CAN
CERTAINLY AFFORD THE COST OF
THE COMPANY TO GET THEIR PETS
SIX. TWENTY THREE REASONS YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR HELP.
OUT THANK YOU MISTER. AND
THERE'S A RED OF THE PER AND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA. YEAH
ANALYSTS ARE KEEN ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT. REGRETFULLY
OPPOSES AB FIVE FIVE THREE AND
IT'S ASKING FOR A NO VOTE FROM
MEMBERS TODAY- INITIATIVE IS TO
INCREASE THE AFFORDABILITY AND
AVAILABILITY OF PROPERTY AND
CASUALTY INSURANCE AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE THINK THAT THE
SELLER COUNTER TO THAT GOAL AND
IN ADDITION TO THE REASONS
STATED BY NEED YEAH CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BILL FOR TWO
ADDITIONAL REASON- YOU KNOW
FIRST ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
TENANTS OF PROPERTY AND
CASUALTY INSURANCE IS THAT
INSURANCE POLICIES PROVIDE
COVERAGE AGAINST LOSSES THAT
CANNOT BE ANTICIPATED LIKE A
CAR CRASH OR FIRE. I THINK IT
INDIAN OUT THAT INSURANCE IS
PROPERTY AND CASUALTY INSURANCE
IT IS THEIR SUPPORT THE
ANALYSTS FINANCIALLY AND
THEY'RE KIND OF HARM AND THEY
CANNOT COVER THAT BUILT
SIMILARLY TO IT SIMILARLY IF
SOMEONE GETS INTO A CAR CRASH
AND NEEDS INSURANCE TO COVER
EXPENSES HOWEVER OUR PETS ARE
LIKE OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
INSURANCE KNOW THAT THAT A WHY
INSURERS HAVE CREATED SEPARATE
WELLNESS PLAN EITHER MORE LIKE
TRADITIONAL HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE CHECK OUT BILLY INTAKE
AND FEARLESSLY SAM. AND ARE
CONVERSELY MORE EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE THEIR. HIGHER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. I
REQUIRED HE AND EXPECT BY SO
WITH PET OWNERS. LIKE THERE'LL
BE. CAN BE. IT WILL LIKELY TAKE
THE FORTY FOR FOLKS WHO NEED
SUPPORT THIS PRODUCT ONLY A THE
AND FORCING THAT PADDOCK HARM
TWENTY THIRD. THREE SECOND
NEARLY TEN AFFAIR NEW PER IN
THE OF IN FOR. EIGHTEEN ONLY TO
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY AND NORTH-
ARE COMPANIES WITH MORE PEOPLE
TO BUY HEALTH AND ONE WAY THAT
WE HOPE TO DO THAT AND BY
MAKING IT. AS AFFORDABLE AS
POSSIBLE FOR FAMILIES. HOWEVER
DISPELLED REQUIRED COVERAGE FOR
STERILIZATION REGARDLESS OF
WHAT WHETHER A PET OWNER WANTS
OR NEEDS THAT COVERAGE. WHEN A
MANDATED PLANS ON INSURANCE
PREMIUMS HAVE TO RISE TO COVER
THAT NEED AND ALTHOUGH AS HE
PREVIOUSLY MANY OF OUR PETS ARE
AIRLINES. WERE WORRIED THAT. A
FIVE THIRTY WHICH IN OUR-
SELECTION. WHEREBY FANS OWNERS
GOAL COVERAGE. ONLY TO COVER
THE COST OF YOUR LOCATION
FEATURE AND THEN CANCEL ABOUT
COVERAGE OF DRIVING UP PREMIUMS
FOR EVERYONE. THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME TO EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS
ASKED WE RESPECTFULLY ASK I
KNOW THE DAY AND- ALL STAY ON
THE LINE WITH CHRISTY ANSWER
AND ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS OKAY
YEAH THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LET'S LET'S GO AHEAD AND
HEAR FROM ANY OTHER PERSONS
WHO- WHO ARE OPPOSING THIS.
BILL ARE THERE OTHERS ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FIVE FIVE
THREE ME PRESS ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AGAIN THE COMMANDOS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE LINE IN QUEUES TO BE
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
SHARON MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANNY
WRITER AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION-
A PTA THE NATIONAL TRADE THAT
NUMBER GREAT 60% AT THE A
PROPERTY AND CASUALTY INSURANCE
MARKET AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
YOU ECHO THE CONCERNS FROM THE
NORTH AMERICAN PET HEALTH
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION. AND ASK
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE NOW ON EIGHTY FIVE FACTORY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS- ON THE NO SIDE. NO
FOR THE MIND AND Q. GOOD THANK
YOU. AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO-
THIS HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- THE MOTION
WOULD BE TO PASS THIS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- IS THERE A
MOTION AND SECOND. ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE WHILE YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT MAKING A MOTION
GO AHEAD SIR. MISTER COOPER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT IS
THE QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
GOOD TO SEE CENTER BY THE WAY-
CURRENTLY- PEOPLE HAVE THE
CHOICE TO PURCHASE A POLICY
BASED ON THE COVERAGE THEY NEED
IF THEIR PETS ARE SPAYED OR
NEUTERED WHY WOULD THEY BUY
POLICY WITH SPARE NEUTER
COVERAGE. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
IT'S SO I THINK IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE HONEST THIS IS STILL A
SMALL POPULATION OF FOLKS THAT
ARE EVEN INTERESTED IN
PURCHASING PET INSURANCE- V.
THE STATEMENTS MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION SORT OF PRESUME THAT
THIS IS STATIC WHERE IF YOU'RE
A PET OWNER YOU'RE ONLY DEALING
WITH ONE PET IN YOUR NEVER
GOING TO GET ANOTHER PET- BUT
WE ALSO KNOW. THAT WITH OTHER
FORMS OF INSURANCE- YOU THERE
ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT ARE
PART OF THE BASIC COVERAGE-
THAT YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO SELECT
THE TO OPT OUT OF AND THIS IS
ELEVATING STERILIZATION TO THAT
LEVEL BASED ON TRUTHFULLY THE
COMMUNITY IMPACT THAT ON
STERILIZED ANIMALS- BECAUSE TO
THE COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW THAT'S
ONE IF YOU HAVE A KID PAT
THAT'S NOT STERILIZE THAT'S OUT
THERE PROCREATING IN OVER
POPULATING THAT ACTUALLY COSTS
MORE- NOT ONLY TO PET OWNERS
pADDITIONAL COSTS- THAT COME
FROM THESE AND I WANT TO SAY
ROGUE ANIMALS BUT ANIMALS OUT
THERE DOING STUFF- IT ALSO
ACCELERATES THE COSTA COUNTY IS
A BENEFIT THAT CAN CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE TO COVER AS IT
RELATES TO DEALING WITH YOUTH
AND IDEATION- AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS DEALING
WITH STERILIZATION AFTER THE
FACT. AND THE- DAMAGE THAT
THOSE ANIMALS CAN ALSO COST TO
NEIGHBORHOODS COMMUNITIES HOMES
NEIGHBORS HOMES ETCETERA. SO IT
IS TRUE. THAT YOU MAY HAVE A
PET NOW. THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
STERILIZED BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE
GIVEN THE DEMOGRAPHIC OF FOLKS
I GET INSURANCE THAT MANY OF
THEM GET INSURANCE FOR PETS
THAT ARE NOT STERILIZED FOLKS
THAT ARE GETTING PADS FROM A
RELATIVE FROM A FRIEND FROM A
BREEDER FROM A STORE. THOSE
PETS DON'T AUTOMATICALLY COME
TO THEM STERILIZED. AND SO THIS
WOULD SAY. IN THIS ACTUALLY
ALSO DOESN'T SAY THAT YOU HAVE
TO GET YOUR ANIMAL STERILIZED
BUT IT DOES SAY THAT IF YOU'RE
GONNA CONSIDER GETTING PET
INSURANCE THAT THIS IS NOT AN
ELECTIVE OPTION. YOU KNOW THE
OPPOSITION DID MENTION THAT
MANY OF THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
DON'T OFFER THIS AND SOME SAY
YOU CAN'T HAVE A PET THAT
STERILIZED WHEN YOU GET
INSURANCE. AND THEIR
EXCLUSIONARY CLAUSES THAT ARE
PART OF THE INSURANCE POLICY
AND THEY SAY THAT BUT IF YOU
GET ONE THAT ISN'T ENSURE THAT
IT'S GOING TO COST YOU MORE. SO
THEY'RE MAKING MONEY ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE EQUATION. WHEN
THIS TRIES TO BRING A LITTLE
MORE EQUITY AND PARITY- ADD TO
THE PET INSURANCE- COVERAGE
POLICIES THAT ARE OFFERED. I
MEAN YOU IT SAYS I GUESS YOU
COULD ALSO TALK ABOUT OTHER
KINDS OF ILLNESSES AND AILMENTS
THAT ANIMALS HAVE- YOU DON'T
THINK MOST PEOPLE I WOULD
ASSUME WE'RE NOT GETTING
INSURANCE THINKING ARE
ANTICIPATING A PROCEDURE IS
GOING TO BE NECESSARY BUT
HOPING THEY DON'T HAVE TO PAY
FOR IT IF IT DOES BECOME
NECESSARY. WOULD YOU AGREE THAT
THE PENSIONS IS NOT CHEAP AT
ALL SO IT'S A IT'S A CERTAIN
UNIQUE MARKET. AND WITH THOSE
FOLKS THE RESPONSIBLE PET
OWNERS ALREADY. SO I GUESS AT
THE END OF THE DAY- THE POLICY.
I GET WITH THE NEW POLICY IS
GONNA COST MORE. SINCE THIS BIG
INNER COVERAGE MANDATE THAT
CORRECT WELL ALL POSTED THE
POLITICAL POLICY WILL GO UP NOW
WELL I WILL SAY THAT- THE
POLICIES. THAT COVER SPAYING
AND NEUTERING ARE FOUR TIMES AS
EXPENSIVE- AS THE MOST
AFFORDABLE POLICIES AND THOSE
AFFORDABLE POLICIES RANGE AND-
FOR TEN TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS A
MONTH- INCREASE IN PREMIUM
COSTS OF RUNNING PREMIUM COST
THE COST TO HAVE THE INSURANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER. OKAY MISTER
COOPER I SEE MR VOEPEL HAS HIS
MIKE UP. FOR A QUESTION OR
COMMENT. COMMENT MISTER CHAIR
PLEASE HOLD ON I'VE ACTUALLY
SOLD PET INSURANCE SO I'VE GOT
SOME EXPERIENCE MAINLY FOR
GROUP AND ASSOCIATION PLANS
PEOPLE BUY PET INSURANCE
BECAUSE THE PETS ARE THEIR
CHILDREN I LOVE THEM AND
GENERALLY THE PETS THAT ARE TWO
YEARS AND OLDER OR ALREADY
SPRAYED AND NEUTERED SO THE
AUTHOR DOES HAVE A POINT THAT
THE PETS UNDER. TWO YEARS OLD.
THIS WOULD COME IN HANDY FOR
NOW. ALL RIGHT LAUD A GREATLY
RESPECT THE INTENT OF THE BILL
BUT THE EXECUTION IS WHAT I
TAKE SOME ISSUES WITH.
GENERALLY PEOPLE FOR THEIR
POLICIES DEPENDING UPON THE
SIZE OF THE GROUP FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OR OFFERED A COUPLE
PLANS ONE WAS BAY- NEUTERING
ONE WITHOUT. AND THEY CHOOSE
WHICH ONE SUITS THEM THE BEST.
GENERALLY AND ONCE AGAIN I'M
JUST THIS IS ANECDOTAL.
GENERALLY THE PEOPLE THAT PICK.
THE POLICIES THAT DON'T INCLUDE
SPACE YOU'RE IN THE NEUTERING
DO IT THEMSELVES PAY FOR
THEMSELVES OF THE GET THE
SHELTER ANIMALS ECCENTRIC NOW.
THE PREMIUMS I HAVEN'T LOOKED
AT FOR MAYBE FIVE SIX YEARS BUT
GENERALLY THE COST BETWEEN THE
TWO OPTIONS ARE NOT THAT
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN
IT'S A ONE TIME COST- THE
COMPANIES THAT I'VE SEEN FOR
FIVE YEARS AGO WOULD ADD ABOUT
EIGHTY CENTS TO A DOLLAR TWENTY
TWO THE MONTHLY PREMIUM. SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ARE SHAKING
MONEY HERE EITHER- I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL SIMPLY%
BECAUSE I SUPPORT CONSUMER
CHOICE. AND THIS WOULD BE AN-
UNFUNDED MANDATE FROM THE STATE
WHICH ALWAYS IRRITATES ME
ANYWAY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR- THANK YOU SIR AND MR CHAN
HAS A COMMENT- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT- I KNOW THAT
HOMELESS PETS HAS BEEN A ISSUE
AND PROBLEM. ALL FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND COMING FROM A
FAMILY OF ANIMAL LOVERS IT WAYS
HAD- PETS IN WHICH WE ADOPTED
FROM THE SHELTER. AND DOES
CLOSE FOR NON MYSELF BUT MY
BROTHER AS WELL AND EVERY TIME
WE GO TO THE SHELTER AS YOU
KNOW UNDER STATE LAW- WHETHER
IT'S A CAT OR A DOG AND BY LAW
THEY HAVE TO SPARE AND NEUTER.
THESE ANIMALS. AND FOR THOSE
THAT WANT TO GET THESE- TAX
FROM ANIMAL SHELTERS AND THEY
ALSO WANT TO PURCHASE
INSURANCE. TO PAY FOR SOMETHING
THAT THEY DON'T NEED I THINK IS
AN ISSUE OF FAIRNESS IS THERE A
POSSIBILITY ABOUT THE AUTHOR
WOULD ANNOTATED UP AND OPT OUT
FOR THOSE TYPE INDIVIDUALS
THAT. ARE ADOPTING A PET FROM A
SHELTER THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SPAYED HAS ALREADY BEEN
NEUTERED DO YOU HAVE A CHOICE
OF OPTING OUT OF THAT. TYPE OF
MANDATED PAYMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN STILL CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS IT WASN'T RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION BUT I TRY TO BE A
COALITION BUILDER WITH MY BILLS
I THINK IT IS AN IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT YOU PEOPLE- A CHOIR.
HEX FROM ALL DIFFERENT IN ALL
DIFFERENT WAYS AND SO IT IS
STILL A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
FOLKS THAT- EVEN OPT TO HAVE
HAD INSURANCE- AND JUST BECAUSE
YOU GET A NOT EVERYONE GETS A
PET GETS A PET FROM THE SHELTER
AND WE KNOW THAT MANY- SHELTERS
DO REQUIRE THAT YOU HAVE YOUR
PETS SPAYED OR NEUTERED IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT FROM
THERE BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER PET
OWNERS THAT ARE GETTING PETS
NOT FROM THEIR SHELTERS- AND SO
THEY'RE ALSO GETTING PETS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN STERILIZED. TO MR
VOEPEL POINT- WE LOOK AT THE
TOTAL COST FOR THE SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF POLICY HOLDERS
THAT ACTUALLY DO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS COVERAGE- WERE THAT
THAT EVERYONE WOULD ACTUALLY
PAY ABOUT FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVEN CENTS PER MONTH AN
ADDITIONAL COST- IF THIS IS
LAW- SO THAT IS A SMALL-
INCREASES SO I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE THAT SINCE THAT HAVE COME
UP. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- AS I
MENTIONED- THAT THIS DOES
HAPPEN THIS BILL AS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION HOWEVER- I GAVE
THE MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A MOTION AND A- IT WAS
PRETTY SILENT- HEY NOW AT THAT
TIME- SO. I'M NOT SURE THERE
WILL BE A VOTE BECAUSE NO ONE'S
MADE A MOTION. DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO ADD
MISS COM LOCAL YOU KNOW I WOULD
JUST ASK FOR CONSIDERATION- AND
HOPE THAT BEFORE- THIS
COMMITTEE INTERNS THAT THAT
THIS MIGHT BE M. BROUGHT UP FOR
A VOTE AND THAT THAT COULD
HAPPEN. I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WANT
FOLKS TO KNOW THAT WE HAD A
VERY GOOD DISCUSSION WITH THE
OPPOSITION YESTERDAY AND WE
ACTUALLY ARE IN AGREEMENT ON
THE CANCELLATION NOTICE WHICH
IS THE PORTION OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. I'M AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT- FOLKS THAT WANT
PET INSURANCE STILL REPRESENT A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE. OF THE
INSURANCE POPULATION BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT NOT HAVING
ANIMAL STERILIZED CONTRIBUTES
TO SO MANY COSTS THAT BOTH PET
OWNERS- AND CITIES AND COUNTIES
HAVE TO BEAR. AND THIS IS
CERTAINLY NOT A SOLUTION THAT
WILL FIX ALL OF- YOU KNOW THE
ISSUES THAT. SURROUND OVER
POPULATION AND USE THAT AS A
NATION OF ANIMALS BUT IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE TO
STEP IN AND DO THEIR PART- WE
DO KNOW THAT I THINK TO PANDIAN
WHICH IS. A BRAND. OR A ONE OF
THE PARTICULAR AT PET INSURANCE
POLICY PRODUCTS- IS. SUGGESTED
TO BE ONE OF THE BETTER PLANS.
IT IS ALSO ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PLANS AND IT IS ALSO
A PLAN THAT SAYS IF YOU'RE
GOING TO GET COVERAGE YOUR PET
CANNOT BE STERILIZED. SO YOU
CAN YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN ANSWER
ALIVE IN ORDER TO GET THE PET
INSURANCE AND THEN IF YOU WANT
YOUR PET TO BE STERILIZED THEN
YOU HAVE TO PAY- AN EXORBITANT
FEE. SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO KIND OF NOT ALLOW THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT ANIMAL
OWNERS DO WANT THEIR PETS TO BE
STERILE THOSE THAT DO DO. AND
WE KNOW THAT INSURANCE
COMPANIES. DON'T WANT TO HAVE
TO WELL WE ALSO KNOW THAT WHEN
ANIMALS ARE NOT STERILIZED.
THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER
HEALTH ISSUES- THAT COMPLICATE
THEIR ABILITY TO LIVE A LIFE
AND ALSO. A RESULT IN MANY
INCREASED COSTS TO THE PET
OWNERS AND SO THIS IS ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY. ON THEFRONT END
TO STOP THOSE KINDS OF COSTS
THAT PET OWNERS WOULD HAVE TO
FACE- SO. ONCE AGAIN I'VE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
CONSIDERATION IN AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS COM LOGGER A
WE'VE HAD A VERY THOROUGH
DISCUSSION AND YOU'VE GIVEN
THIS- VERY EARNEST. EFFORT HERE
ON A SUBJECT THAT CLEARLY IS
NEAR AND DEAR TO YOUR HEART.
YES AN IMPORTANT SUBJECT TO
MANY PEOPLE BUT- I THINK THE
COMMITTEE YOU GET A SENSE OF
THE COMMITTEE HEARING NOW THAT
TO- ALL RIGHT WELL NEXT TIME. I
COME WITH ANOTHER PET INSURANCE
I WILL PERMISSION TO BRING MY
PET TO MAKE A. DISPLAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD MISS
GONZALEZ THANK YOU WE HAVE AN
ERROR I HAVE NO PETS AS
CHILDREN GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AB ONE TWENTY THREE WOULD
ALLOW WORKERS USING THE STATE'S
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM TO
RECEIVE 90% INCOME REPLACEMENT
UP TO- THE LIMIT OF ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN DOLLARS PER WEEK MISS
GONZALEZ- I'M IN A SECOND-
MISTER MAYES MOTIONS WITH THE
MOTION SECOND ON YOUR BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE GOOD. GOOD ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MR FRAZIER DID YOU
HAVE YOU HAD A QUESTION. YES
QUESTION THE AUTHOR AND I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU- THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS HOW YOU
FORMAT IT WAS JUST ONE QUESTION
I HAVE. IT JUST BASED ON ALL OF
WHAT OUR COLLEAGUES AND YOU AND
I HAVE. OCCURRED WITH AN
EXPERIENCED. LATELY SAYS IF A
FIRST CLAIM IS NOT COMPLETE THE
CLAIM FORM SHALL BE RETURNED TO
THE CLAIMANT FOR COMPLETION AND
SHALL BE COMPLETED RETURNED AND
NOT LATER THAN TEN CONSECUTIVE
DAYS. THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE. I'M
SORRY THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE WITH
THE AGENCIES WITH THE BACK
ROADS AND WHAT AND- WHAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING I THINK THAT'S
EXISTING LAW I'M NOT SURE WHAT
YOU'RE READING FROM THE I DON'T
THINK I I'VE CHANGED. THAT BUT
WHAT I'M SAYING IS IN THAT
COMPONENT I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT YOUR STAFF HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY- COMPROMISE WITH THE
V. D. N. STI ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY DO AND I JUST SANDERS
THIS. IS BASICALLY YOU KNOW A
PIPE DREAM AS FAR AS TEN DAYS
WE WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU KNOW THERE THERE NEEDS
TO BE A REASONABLE APPROACH.
AND NOT PUT THIS. THIS COMPLETE
COMPONENT WITH A TEN DAY
EXPECTATIONS. SO WE CAN YOU
KNOW AT LEAST AS IT GOES
FORWARD. LOOK AT THAT- CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT IF THEY'RE
GONNA MAKE THAT. HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO MAKE THAT BASED ON
WHAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED RIGHT I
BELIEVE WHAT YOU'RE READING
FROM IS NOT SOMETHING WE'RE
CHANGING IT'S AN EXISTING LAW
THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO LOOK. AT
IT AND OBVIOUSLY I. A LITTLE-
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE'RE
CHANGING A LOT. UNDERSTANDABLE
OKAY THE ADDITIONAL WHEN THE
CHANGES YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT
MAYBE LOOK AT CHANGING THAT AS
WELL YES PLEASE OKAY BECAUSE OF
THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD BECAUSE
OF THIS. NEW COMPONENT OF YOUR
IN INTRODUCING. AND HOPEFULLY
DOES PASS THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE IN. AND GET SIGN.
THAT THIS THIS COMPONENT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED BECAUSE OF THE
ADDITIONAL WORK. I WILL LOOK AT
THAT THING AGAIN SHE ADDED
OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
AND MAYBE THIS BILL CAN BE THE
VEHICLE TO. TRANSFORM E. D. D.
OR A TO A BETTER OPERATION BUT
THAT'S YOUR THAT'S YOUR BASIC
POINT IS THERE STRUGGLING
ALREADY. WAIT WAIT WAIT SO I'M
SORRY THIS IS NOT MY EIGHTY
BILL THIS IS PAID FAMILY LEAVE
BILL ARE YOU. ARE WE IN THE FBI
OKAY SO YOU'RE READING FROM THE
STI PORTION OF THE CODE OKAY I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE BUT YES
ALL RUN BY EDT THAT AS OUR YEAH
I'M NOW I'M CONFUSING MYSELF.
YEAH YOU KNOW THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION I THINK- IT WAS A
KIND OF A CIRCULAR DISCUSSION
ON PET INSURANCE- SQ EXCUSE US
FOR BEING PUNCHY- ANYTHING ELSE
ON THIS BILL ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THERE'S A
MOTION AND SECOND MISS GONZALEZ
ANYTHING ELSE TO SAY ON THIS
ONE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I'VE A- ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
FILE ITEM THREE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. DALY HI DALY I
MAYES. MAYES AYE BERMAN.
BIGELOW. I'M SORRY BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOW. CHEN. CHEN NOT
VOTING COOPER. COOPER I FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON GRAYSON
MASON I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL NOT VOTING WHAT
WOOD I. WE NEED A MISTER COOLEY
NEEDS A STRUGGLING. MR COOLEY
AYE. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN-
I THINK- MISTER GIBSON IS- IS
ON HIS WAY C. OKAY. HEDGE I
LEARNED A LOT YES WHAT WAS THE
ROLL CALL WHAT WAS THE VOTE. IN
YEARS MR GIPSON. OUR ALL RIGHT.
IS THAT EVERYONE. YES I'M IN A
CALL MISTER GIBSON ON THE
COMMITTEE ROLES AND ON FILE
ITEM THREE. MISTER GIBSON ON
THE COMMITTEE ROLES. GIPSON I.
FILE ITEM THREE DO PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GIPSON. OTHER IS THAT THE RULES
ARE NOTES FILE ITEM THREE AB
ONE TWENTY THREE DO PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. GIPSON HI.
THAT'S WHAT IS ALL THIS BILL.
AND WE NEED YOU TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND ON RULES.
OKAY. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
GIPSON GIPSON AYE. AN INVESTOR
COOLEY. ON CONSENT. CONSENT
CALENDAR COOLEY REALLY I. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
GOT IT DONE. ON THE COMMITTEE
ROLES COOLEY COOLEY AYE AT THAT
TIME IT'S A NICE TIME. THAT'S
THAT'S ATTENTION GETTING. YEAH
WE DON'T HAVE. ONE COLLEGE
OFFICE IF YOU MISTER BERMAN A-
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MR BERMAN IF HE'S- IF HE'S HERE
IN THE BUILDING. IS CHAIRING
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS. WELL- YOUR
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR A LITTLE
WHILE. HE'S NORMALLY A VERY
DUTIFUL MEMBER OF OUR COMMITTEE.
YEAH THAT'S IT YEAH YEAH IN THE
BUSINESSES CONCLUDED BUT
LEAVING THE ROLE OPEN.
FOLLOWING. FOLLOWING THE. LEARN
HI. ANOTHER ROLE THAT. ONE OF
MY- YOU HAVE A GOOD IDEA TO BUY
WINDOWS PEOPLE. YOU JUST WALKED
OUT OF. WELL THANK YOU FOR.
NICE JOB BUT. I DIDN'T. YEAH.
YES. MONDAY.
YEP MR BERMAN
WERE- WE'RE READY FOR YOU USER
COMMITTEE RULES CONSENT
CALENDAR AND TO BUILD. ALTHOUGH
ONE OF THE BILL. ON THE
COMMITTEE ROLES BERMAN BERMAN I
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR BERMAN.
BERMAN I. FILE ITEM THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN. WITH THE OTHER THE BILL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ.
BERMAN I. THAT YOU'VE BEEN OKAY
GOOD JOB THANKS. THIS HEARINGS
ADJOURNED.